when we consumers buy these strawberries
at a bargain all too often it comes at a
great human cost for non-eu seasonal
workers amazing stipend squad housing
and at times even slavery are the daily
lot for the 100 000 seasonal workers
coming to work in the eu every year
we have to remember many seasonal
workers are working in very isolated
conditions you know we talk about sweden
or finland you know the very north of
the country where we have seasonal
workers doing berry picking
from thailand and from malaysia in spain
and italy there's the areas we see more
coverage of in greenhouses and isolated
farms they're in a very vulnerable
situation and the exploitation that they
experience often doesn't trickle through
to us
meps are now stepped up their
responsibilities voting overwhelmingly
for a directive aimed at improving
conditions for those workers often
working here illegally from now on
employers must provide decent housing
and workers are guaranteed a minimum
wage social rights and a 9-12 month visa
for bad employers we have the threat of
sanctions but we also have an
inspections regime so that we have an
inspection of workplaces around the
european union and it's very much up to
the member states to deal with this but
remember this is not created as a burden
on on businesses we worked with the
social partners with business and with
the trade unions to check that this was
not an undue burden on them the reform
package will reduce the unfair advantage
that non-eu workers have over eu workers
some meps want to go further
the new european
in 2016.